alors il ya quelques jours vous avez
posté des photos de vous sans votre
toiture bon des photos massivement
commentée par la presse
c'est fou le boss que vous pouvez faire
parce que c'est vrai que deux ans après
partout on a parlé vous on va dire voilà
là elle a enlevé son turban c'est vrai
que alors que vous pensez de ces
commentaires je pense que de toute façon
quoi qu'on fasse dans la vie il y aura
toujours des personnes pour pourrait
être un accord un désaccord pour savoir
mieux que soi même ce qu'on doit faire
en l'occurrence j'ai porté un turban sur
ma tête je faisais le choix de couvrir
mes cheveux donc c'est mon choix et
aujourd'hui je ne pouvais plus mes
cheveux tout le temps pourquoi parce que
c'est mon choix pour vous avez changé
d'avis parce que c'est mon chemin
spirituel
d'accord vous avez dans cette ma vie
elle tourne pas qu'autour de la musique
chez d autres choses c'est à dire que
quand je me lève le matin tous mes choix
de vie ne sont pas systématiquement
défini par ma carrière mais qu'est-ce
qui a fait que ça a changé parce que
mine de rien vous étiez présenté à the
voice oui avec votre tour bon oui
j'étais une personne avec certaines
convictions et puis j'étais comme cela à
ce moment là aujourd'hui j'ai évolué je
change je deviens quelqu'un des
différents films turcs avant d'aller sur
ces soutiens même personne c'est sûr
qu'au 6 à votre âge on peut on peut
changer on peut je pense que c'est
logique puis on passe tous par un
cheminement qui soit spirituel ou
d'entendre de développement personnel et
à partir de là je pense avoir le droit
quand même de décider de changer d'
adapter ma vie selon cette bien dans
votre peau aujourd'hui vous êtes bien
beaucoup mieux plus apaisé parce que
j'apprends en fait tu as à dire aux gens
voilà je suis comme ça et je n'ai pas à
me travestir et j'ai pas à plaire à tout
le monde parce que je sais que ce que
j'offre c'est sincère et c'est
authentique
je sais qu'avec mon coeur est avec ce
qui m'anime du plus profond